imagine two people who have never met
could do an amazing trick Alice and Bob
are allowed to communicate over a line
which is tapped so any message they pass
will be intercepted by Eve who is always
listening the trick is to agree on a
secret numerical key without Eve also
obtaining a copy how is this possible
first let's explore how this trick is
done using colors so how could a lesan
Bob agree on a secret color without
evening it out the trick is based on two
facts one it's easy to mix two colors
together to make a third color and to
give it a mixed color it's hard to
reverse it in order to find the exact
original colors this is the basis for a
lock easy in one direction hard in the
reverse direction
this is known as a one-way function now
the solution works as follows first they
publicly agree on a starting color say
yellow next Alice and Bob both randomly
select private colors and mix them into
the public yellow in order to disguise
their private color
now Alice keeps her private color and
sends her mixture to Bob and Bob keeps
his private color and sends his mixture
to Alice now the heart of the trick
Alice and Bob add their private colors
to the other person's mixture and arrive
at a shared secret color
notice how Eve is unable to determine
this color since she needs one of the
private colors to do so and that is the
trick now to do this with numbers we
need a numerical procedure which is easy
in one direction and hard in the reverse
direction this brings us to modular
arithmetic which is known as clock
arithmetic for example to find 42 mod 12
we take a rope of length 46 units and
wrap it around a clock of 12 units which
is called the modulus and wherever the
rope ends is the solution so we say 42
mod 12 is congruent to 10 easy
now to make this work we need a prime
modulus such as 17 instead of 12 then we
find the primitive root of 17 which is a
number that has no factors in common in
this case 3 and it has this important
property that when raised to different
exponents the solution distributes
uniformly around the clock 3 is known as
the generator so if we raise 3 to any
exponent X the solution is equally
likely to be any integer between 0 & 17
now the reverse procedure is hard say
given 12 find the exponent 3 needs to be
raised 2 this is called the discrete
logarithm problem and now we have our
one wave function easy to perform but
hard to reverse given 12 you would have
to resort to trial and error in order to
find the matching exponent how hard is
this well with small numbers it's easy
but if we use a prime modulus which is
hundreds of digits long it starts to get
seriously hard even if you had access to
all the computational power on earth it
could take thousands of years or more to
find the answer so the strength of a
one-way function is based on the time
needed to reverse it now this is our
solution first Alice and Bob publicly
agree on a prime modulus and a generator
for example 17 and 3 then Alice selects
a private random number say 54 and
calculates 3 to the power 54 mod 17 and
sends this result publicly to Bob then
Bob selects his private random number
say 24 and calculates 3 to the power 24
mod 17 and sends this result publicly to
Alice and now the heart of the trick
Alice takes Bob's public result and
raises it to the power of her private
number which gives 3 to the power 24
times 54 and she obtains the shared
secret which in this case is 1 Bob takes
Alice's public result and raises it to
the power of his private number which
gives 3 to the power of 54 times 24
resulting in the same
shared secret notice they did the same
calculation with the exponents in a
different order 24 times 54 is the same
as 54 times 24 without one of the
private numbers Eve will not be able to
find the solution and this is how it's
done while Eve is stuck grinding away at
the discrete logarithm problem and with
large enough numbers this will literally
take forever